fox news propagandist tucker carlson is
really playing up this fox news crisis
at the border story of course the crisis
at the border
started three days after joe biden took
off it's it's amazing how quickly he was
able to start a crisis at the border and
fox news has really been playing this up
and
uh this is just a perfect red meat issue
for tucker carlson and last night
tucker did a segment on his show arguing
that the country
suddenly is too crowded and that crowded
countries
are unhappy countries let's take a
listen to tucker carlson
has there ever been an administration
this reckless and destructive
what's happening on the border site will
change this country forever a lot of
things won't this will and you should
know that
unlike other disasters mass illegal
immigration is permanent
no one ever really gets sent home over
the past 30 years the population of the
united states has exploded by nearly a
hundred
million people mostly due to immigration
were you even aware that that happened
you're not supposed to say a word about
it as every year the united states gets
steadily more
jammed with people and at the same time
more chaotic and less cohesive
as the open spaces shrink as nature
itself recedes in the face of yet
another strip mall
or apartment complex or fast food outlet
to serve the new people
this is becoming a crowded country and
crowded countries are ugly unhappy
countries
why are we letting that happen so there
are about five
layers of things to talk about here and
i i really hope that these
segments are instructive for i think
these are great because
we start with just like a cartoonish or
wacky thing from right-wing media
which i think interests a lot of people
but then we actually
look at the data behind a lot of these
things and hopefully we come out with a
better understanding of how the world
works
first of all is just the political
posturing and the hypocrisy why do this
segment
55 what is it 56 days into joe biden's
presidency
but you never did it during donald
trump's presidency given that if the
issue is the country being crowded
during the time that donald trump was in
office the u.s population
increased by 6 to 7 million
people and tucker said nothing about the
country being too crowded
and yet during joe biden's 50-something
days in office
during which the u.s population probably
increased by about a hundred thousand
people
all of a sudden now the country is just
stuffed full of people it's too crowded
the answer is to why he didn't do it
then and he's doing it now
is because he only cares about this
issue when a democrat is president
that's very simple
number two tucker often focuses
on what he considers the tragedy of
cities
which i guess he believes are sort of
war zone
hellscapes but the truth is that the us
is large cities surrounded by
gigantic areas with very few or almost
no people
in many states and in fact if you
actually rank
countries by overall population density
the us
i i think this will shock many of you
the us is 145th in the world
in population density we are right
behind
mozambique and venezuela and the faroe
islands
in population density but just ahead
of kyrgyzstan latvia and dystonia in
population density yes our population
density is
lower than that of the pharaoh islands
so
it's also not crowded many cities are
but people are choosing to live there
and if it became
uh too uncomfortable to live in those
cities there's plenty of open space that
people can find and if tucker's looking
for open space
certainly there's plenty for him as well
now then he gets to happiness in terms
of happiness
happiness i have studied in fact my uh
my masters
here we go my master's uh not really
dissertation
but one of my like final master's papers
was on uh happiness correlations
and there is no evidence that population
density correlates with happiness
however
a lot of economic factors do and people
can be happy
in cities or in suburbs or in rural
areas but it really depends on having a
job
economic stability social connections
access to health care which is part of
being able to sort of
determine what you want to do in life
and then lastly
population growth in the united states
is really slow right now
the population grew at the slowest rate
in 120 years
between 2019 and 2020
just 0.35
so this is another fake scandal
where tucker and fox and newsmax and
others
they want you to think that the
immigration crisis suddenly
is so bad that the country is now
crowded
by no measure is the united states
crowded
but then here's the additional layer of
irony
the real population concern is not about
oh it's too crowded there's no room the
real population concern is not
immigrants are flooding the no it's none
of that
the population concern is climate change
and sustainability
the most science-based concern about
you know you could say world population
or u.s population
is energy consumption and resource
depletion
and that's the one that tucker doesn't
actually care about
he at least doesn't talk about it and he
ridicules climate science
and he ridicules those who are concerned
about resource use
in the united states and what was
notably absent from that
rant a fact-free rant a propagandistic
rant
was the real concern about listen at a
certain point
what are we doing to the natural
resources of our planet what are we
doing in terms of emissions what are we
doing in terms of all of these other
things
if the con if the world population
continues increasing at the current pace
now
this ignores all sorts of population
dynamics and
and theories you know you've got um uh
uh thomas thomas malthus and there's all
this different
literature about this that's out there
certainly it's beyond tucker's segment
but the point is if you want to have a
real conversation
about the impacts of an indefinitely
increasing population
it's a climate change conversation it's
an environmentalism conversation it's a
sustainability conversation
you're not going to find that on
tucker's show anytime soon that i can
assure you
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy
app and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com pacman